what's up good humans we love
collaborating with you on prompts for
middle ground so find out how to
collaborate with us stick around to the
end and we'll tell you how enjoy the
episode I'm a human and so I have flaws
and I'm thankful for the way I look but
I'm not perfect and so I'd like to
represent myself and sometimes I'll look
and like see these filters and people
look like aliens I would say like booty
stuffing on the UH on the screen yeah I
think there's a big difference I've gone
till all the Fashion Week's Paris London
Milan New York when I think runway model
I think Victoria's Secret I think real
swim I've heard a lot do it work for
Instagram like oh well I'm the new plan
sir I have about seventy one thousand
right now I have 160 mm I'm about 850
okay almost one way I'm curious to see
what the runway models think of us
Instagram photos do you know that it is
a job and not just something to get free
clothes would my name is Vitoria I'm 26
I'm a social-media influencer Instagram
model and social media content creator
my name is Miriam
I am Instagrammer I'm an influencer
social media creator and I'm 29
hi my name's Gary Lawson I'm 35 and I'm
a professional male model and runway
month hi my name is Jessica Britten
Mayer I'm 19 and I'm a runway model hi
guys my name is ELISA g'yahhhh I'm 34
years old I'm an international model hi
everyone I'm Chantal I am 24 and I am a
body positive influence her as well as a
curb model
and my runway mouse on the right if you
agree come to the middle
my job is inclusive of all body types
races genders sexuality so I know mine
is very much inclusive you see me see
how I look the people that follow me
they're here to pretty much gain
confidence I get messages from women all
the time you know I love the way you
look I look like that too I feel like
going up I always saw models that you
have to be tall and stuff so I'm glad
for social media you could just brand
yourself the way you are and just be
yourself when I was growing up I was
never thinking that I can be a model
because I was never at the model n type
now I'm represented by an agency I work
with a worldwide brand I could never
think that that would ever happen to me
and I'm so grateful it's not inclusive
all body types because generally the
things that I'm wearing are not made
from all body types so in order to do my
job I have to maintain a certain you
know form you know a certain shape for
runway models what these designers are
creating our sample sizes and you have
to be able to fit into this sample sizes
so that's mostly why it's not as
inclusive of body type I guess but I
definitely do believe that the modeling
industry is becoming more diverse yeah
especially like nowadays I would love to
say that you know the modeling industry
and clothes everybody it does include
races and everyone but it's true when we
talk about body type people have to be a
certain height and a certain you know
she body shape to be able to do it is
like comparing someone who plays tennis
and plays for fun and someone who plays
professionally and actually train for
years for that as well like a Roger
Federer not everyone gets to be him and
it's the same thing for models as well
it's like we don't really choose how we
were born or the height we have
and we get to do that job people have to
be really lean or they now there's like
plus-size models but in between there's
no market for the in between and normal
people it's a shame that should change I
think absolutely we were talking about
it like your size 14 to 16 right nice
sample size 4 plus 16 that's you know
the 1x that's the standard for their
models yeah and for example I am size 6
to 8 and for me there is no sample size
you know and I am forced to work with
the brands which are Digital brands
rather than cateura
and that's why I'm more stuck to
Instagram modeling versus I can in the
runway I think the most difficult part
is that it's not just a job that you go
to but it's kind of a lifestyle that you
have to live I don't think anyone can
just be a runway model I think first of
all Kevin Russell gave a TED talk and
she talks about how being a model is
like winning the genetic lottery so I
think most of it is definitely luck but
not only that but you have to live a
certain lifestyle and I think only
people that are very have a strong will
and self-determination can really do it
I agree it's also I feel the same thing
for the Instagram the casting director
looks at you cos you you walk the show
and that said for us is different we
have to build community we have to hit
like hundreds of thousands people to
like us and wants to follow us every day
we're like if you think of it we collect
like a small city like worth of people
who are actually with us supporting us
and helping us and we do the same for
them in 2018 for instance only in
America they are there are 257 million
people who have a smartphone and out of
these people 80 percent of people are in
social media any one of these 80 percent
can actually become an Instagram model
and I think that really very a very very
small portion of people can become a
fashion model
is completely different because if you
take away the makeup if you take away
the filters if you take away maybe the
plastic surgery and all the retouching
see what is really at the end I wouldn't
necessarily agree with that and I can
say why the thing is we don't treat as
photos that much anymore because we do
body positivity and we're actually proud
to show this industry has moved a lot
away from what it used to be oh the
filter oh editing if anything the
influencers nowadays we're trying to
break that down we're trying to break
down the filters we're trying to break
down you know hiding behind facetune and
photoshopping or whatever that you
know we got on our phones these days and
yeah I think that it's just it's
starting to become more raw that's why I
think that we're we're on the front line
to you know where we're posting all our
flaws and every little role in stretch
mark and everything and it's up for
people to judge my feet I'm more
lifestyle blogger recently I
concentrated a lot on sports and on the
workout and how to be healthy because
I'm really against plastic surgeries and
I'm trying to emphasize a lot that
people can be pretty and healthy by
working on themselves and eating
properly versus just going to the
surgeon
well I broke my nose three years ago and
it's like not a fake story actually like
my nose my nose is still crooked um I
broke her nose like three years ago and
I had to get my nose done and I did
remove the bump because you already
paying for it so might as well I'm sure
that made you happy it made me very
happy like I honestly was insecure about
my bump and I was getting a lot of not
you know not the good compliments
necessarily about it I loved it but
still people were like you know and yeah
it made me very happy I still couldn't
fix the whole thing but what did you do
breast augmentation okay yeah I mean
it's just an enhancement it was
something that was gonna make me happier
so I just did it for confident for you
yeah I just feel like for Asian girls
like we're not gifted and like we're
gifted with our genetics like Asian some
reasons but like when it comes to our
body like we need to put in either like
the finance or like the work in it I had
like the tiniest funny nose when I was
little and I was oh my god like I didn't
like my nose you know it was weird
shaped and and when I grew up being a
model then the photographer's were like
oh my god we love you nose I was like
who my nose okay and it really taught me
to accept it and I love it now I'm so
glad you know I never thought about
doing any surgery or my nose or anything
but you know he taught me to love myself
the way I am so enough of that I've had
like a similar experience I'm half
Japanese so I wasn't really no Oeste
that it curves but and I used to not
like that I used to be like oh when
people see me you know I don't like a
track if I don't have boobs they don't
have a butt but as soon as I got into
the modeling world they're like oh no
that's a good thing it's good to be
flattered I was like oh okay and I have
something
I think I think for me just being a you
know all-inclusive it's a little like
you know I can't really say like don't
do anything because I'm supposed to be
supportive of all body types however you
come however you want to come is how I
accept you but I think where I am right
now
100% natural um I think that's like
where I'd like to stay just for my
message you know to everyone that's
watching me right now maybe a couple
years down the line after a couple kids
I'm hanging down here or something you
know so I'm not gonna say never and I
did I disagree with it but for where I'm
at in my space right now I definitely am
our true beauty I admire people how they
come come natural and I think that if
anything it makes you more unique so
it's staying on top of it it's always
I'm coming out with new ideas new photos
new outfits like making sure like the
photo is perfect when you're posting for
me specifically when I'm thinking about
Photoshop which might be different than
you guys for a lot of the photos that
I'm in maybe you'll have like acne that
day and a lot of times they'll Photoshop
that out and they'll make your skin
clear and to me that's okay because
that's things that go away whereas I
think for body I'm not against I'm not
for that I have to admit I have
Photoshop my photos before but it's just
to make to enhance the photo to make it
look a certain way but I still look Who
I am
it's not like I look completely
different I think that as long as you're
not seeing people in person they're like
I think that that's I think it's fine
like you said and when you're in
magazines you know I've seen my pictures
on econ and there guys are smooth
there's no cellulite and you know what
that sells the clothes it gets things
done
it's what the customers want to see and
I'm perfectly okay with that I'm not
cool with it before you start like have
you two never been photoshopped like
nobody has ever retouched your photos in
no way no the question is are we okay
with it that's a different question but
yes because you know I'm not saying I'll
be honest I'm not saying I'm never
retouching my photos yes but it does not
make it okay let's say I don't like too
much makeup either you know I mean but I
think when it comes to retouching I
don't have control of the image I do the
job and then they have control of that
image so that's one thing like I if it
were to me I would like to be as natural
book natural as possible because I want
I'm a human and so I have flaws and I'm
thankful for the way I look but I'm not
perfect and so I'd like to represent
myself like I'd like to be this is who I
am and sometimes I'll look and like see
these filters and people look like
aliens like they don't even look like
you know excite this crazy feeling I'm
like what is that would you refuse a job
if you would know they're gonna
photoshop the hell out of you if they're
gonna Photoshop the hell out of me then
I'm not doing the job essentialy yeah
like it's not it's not me then you might
as well get anything it's like my photo
looks good and I don't look like too
hourglass like I'm fine with it but how
do you decide if you're okay with it
then you're okay with them doing
whatever they want I get to have my own
photographer makeup artists and my
photographer at is my photos so we can
always collaborate on like reshaping and
stuff so it's not like a magazine what
is the best part
the best part is the supporters the
girls that message me and they say you
know you give me so much confidence and
I love the way you look and now I can go
out and look that way too so that's
definitely what gives me
versus the girls that I influence
so I think anyone who works with image
and have their image up there has a
responsibility to really send a positive
and healthy message because for instance
I remember when I started modeling there
was always that oh you need to lose
weight you need to lose weight and I
could have gone that route but I decided
you know I I lost a little bit just to
like fit the sample size but I didn't
want to go that route because it's
unhealthy and then I'm setting it I'm
setting an example for younger women
they're gonna think that's the image of
beauty they're gonna think you know it's
it's okay to do that it concerns me so
much the body implants because people
actually die from it and I started yeah
I literally start working out five times
a week with a trainer yeah just to show
them that you can build the butt because
you have it naturally and it's gorgeous
I don't have you know and I wish I would
have it and I tried to turn and grow the
body you know and also I think for the
curve models we deal with the other end
of like is it too much you know is it is
it too is she too big you know are you
promoting obesity are you saying that
it's okay to be unhealthy and I think
that has a curved model it's our
responsibility to say like hey yeah
we're curvy but we're still promoting
you know healthy lifestyles I try to
tell my girls you know that are
following me like yeah girl I might have
a little you know something back here
but I'm still eating my broccoli every
day so each of Radley I guess for me I
just really never thought that I had any
influence at all
I never whenever I did like a photo
shoot or anything I never even thought
that other people I guess would see it
but the more that I'm thinking about it
I guess I do have some sort of influence
not as much as Instagram models because
your whole life is kind of on display
when people see images of me it's just
that it's just an image and I like to
think that I do influence people in like
a positive way cuz I'm definitely not
like the skinniest model at my agency
I've never had any eating disorders at
all so I like to think that even though
I didn't really think about it too much
that I am positively impacting people
that are looking at me
influences our responsibility is
probably just the things that we that we
post and I'm not gonna be posting diet
pills and you know things of that like
shakes and teas and whatever that makes
you your pants I'm not gonna post
this so I think that that's our
responsibility is to just you know just
kind of filter in what we're putting out
when it comes to sponsorship if I'm like
agreeing to something I have to try the
product first so after trying if it
doesn't work I'll tell them it doesn't
work and I wouldn't want to continue on
so just depends I have worked for
designers like Alexander McQueen walk
the show Paul Costello like big
designers okay we all know most
influencers are working with fast
fashion so we're getting the closed ASAP
things are coming out you can get a
million of those same dresses and we all
have them on college and only I get
money from like a couple of modeling
gigs over here and there yeah I mostly
like Goodwill's my go-to first of all I
can't afford everything I work because
some like I'm not I would not buy a five
thousand ten thousand dollar suit it
just doesn't make sense to me there's
also a thing to getting free things and
not getting paid on top of it so there's
it's there's levels to it I would say
yeah so if I'm doing stuff for free
clothes and not getting paid then I'm
not gonna be able to afford anything
because I'm not getting paid and I find
that a lot of times a good percentage of
Instagram influencers or models are just
like I'm gonna do it for the clothes I
can't pay my bills from with clothes you
know I can't pay anything with clothes a
lot of Instagram models just are key to
get free clothes so suddenly then brands
will just not pay models and take
Instagram models and it's completely
watering down the model rate and it's
cutting the grass there
so it's a real problem in our industry
yeah I've noticed that over the past few
years where it's just like rates that
are unbelievably low like for usages
that are unbelievably high and it's like
but someone's gonna say yes just because
they want to be seen and that like we
have to know our worth so far is the way
works you start with a free clothes and
you guys correct me if for you was any
different it starts with a free clothes
you say okay to build the relationship
with the brand and then you get close
and you get paid for that like for
example I live fully from my Instagram
like I supported myself you know I can
pay my bills I can pay my could pay my
rent I'm really proud with it now and
they're gonna or undersell youtube's
you're gonna stop making money because
everyone's real but everyone's gonna
yeah start doing it for less and less
and less it's not true like because they
want us for our following they don't
want us they they want us for the way we
look that's true the content brands are
looking for influencers that are selling
the pictures they have quality they're
posting consistently of course there's a
bunch of people out there that yeah I'll
post it in my backyard with my you know
iPhone and it just doesn't work they'll
those influencers definitely get washed
away not being sure of when you're going
to work next and to fill your time with
like being a human being
but like not knowing like not having
control of like your day I guess that
would probably be it for me
working in this job for 15 years there's
been waves which I was like wow like I
really put my worth into what other
people think if I get a job it's based
on someone saying oh I like the way you
look which is a very minimal thing to be
able to judge a person by when you have
a lot of things going on inside of you
you know I started modeling in New York
City where even when I started there
were in a lot of us like dark black men
modeling and having to be like the only
one or like breaking the barrier or like
going to you know Cass since oh well
he's too dark I can't do anything about
being dark or not you know but it kind
of broke me a little bit and I would
have to like I'd have to leave town and
I'd have to go to New York to work
because I couldn't do it in the place
that I wanted to live it definitely
affected my mental health for a while
it's like they're searching for this
this certain look that's like you know
they love to use this word like racially
ambiguous you know things like that and
it's like do you want a black someone
that is like trying to mimic a black
model that I'm here what's up and so
Graham became a numbers game right
engagement comments like so for sure it
had effect on me so if a photo wasn't
doing too well I start thinking and over
thinking to myself like wow what did I
do wrong like I'll try to delete this
poll so it's just like I started being a
model at the age of 20 years old which
is considered late for the business and
I think I'm very grateful that I started
later on in the business because if I
had started at 14 like a lot of girls
whatever your agent tells you whatever
you know the client says you're so
affected by it you take whatever it is
they add the whole truth okay need to
lose weight okay I'm gonna do it you
need to do look that way okay I'm gonna
do it as if you start a little bit older
I had the chance that you know I had
that maturity but it doesn't mean that I
didn't affect me of course you wanna be
booked you want to be liked by the
client so you try to please everyone but
you can never please everyone there's
always a client is not gonna like your
look or not gonna like you know the way
you walk or your personality or your
hair whatever it is if they pick you
apart basically
so it was really hard because you can
start this job with so much confidence
but the industry is gonna break you down
and then it's about then accepting
myself and be like you know what I don't
need your validation I don't need that
and when you come in then I had to build
myself up again and now I go to jobs
unlike you like me awesome if you don't
next one is right there
it's alright you know and you just got
to be like brush it off that's alright
next one you know and yeah definitely
not easy
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you good humans for watching
another episode of middle ground we love
collaborating with you guys as you've
seen we love getting prompts from you
the way to submit prompts is to follow
us on Instagram we have stories on there
for your prompts as well as following us
on the YouTube app on your phone one of
our most air things about just this
community we've built is being able to
hear from you interact with you get
ideas from you and just have this
conversation so make sure you follow
along and we will see you guys next time